i
bienvenidos al debate de france 24 soy
santiago lópez gonzález una nueva
investigación del consorcio
internacional de periodistas de
investigación conocida como papeles de
pandora dio a conocer una nueva red de
fideicomisos y también de sociedades
fantasmas conformadas por 35 líderes
mundiales 14 de ellos latinoamericanos y
varios funcionarios todo esto en
paraísos fiscales como por ejemplo las
islas vírgenes británicas
panamá o el estado de dakota del sur en
eeuu todo esto para evitar pagar
impuestos aquí les explicamos de qué se
trata
los pandora papers ponen de nuevo la
lupa sobre la industria de paraísos
fiscales y sociedades offshore una red
de fideicomisos opacos de empresas de
papel y élites mundiales cómo se crean
estas entidades primero es un destino
distinto al de la residencia de su
beneficiario france24 habló con ewald
scharfenberg periodista venezolano y
miembro de la investigación y eso
sociedades que buscan esos destinos
a conseguir en jurisdicciones donde la
supervisión del estado o la carga
tributaria es muy baja y eso permite
justamente
evitar el pago de impuestos o sobre todo
ocultar
fondos que tienen digamos
orígenes oscuros si bien su creación es
legal el problema surge cuando estas
sociedades se esconden en jurisdicciones
opacas sin declarar a las autoridades
del país donde el propietario tiene su
residencia fiscal real y así no pagar
impuestos estas mismas dos mismas
refugios tributarios como hay también
coinciden con muy pocos requisitos para
de control por parte del estado
normalmente son utilizados para quienes
financian actividades ilícitas o quienes
tienen dinero proveniente de la
corrupción o que por ejemplo están
financiando el terrorismo suelen
utilizar también esas vías américa
latina pierde más de 40 mil millones de
dólares en impuestos cada año debido a
estas estructuras
además los pandora papers revelan cómo
gran parte de la élite política mundial
independientemente de sus signos
políticos está implicada esa clase
política que es la que debería ponerle
costo a estas prácticas
bufetes y bancos internacionales en
impuestos o prácticas rutinarias en el
mundo financiero internacional pues
dejaría no pueden poner de costos porque
también son parte interesada pues tras
la magnitud de estas investigaciones una
de las dudas que quedan en el aire es
cuáles pueden ser las consecuencias
jurídicas de los involucrados
en los 14 líderes latinoamericanos 11 ya
han dejado el poder tres de ellos están
en el mandato en este momento el
ecuatoriano guillermo lazo el presidente
de chile sebastián piñera y el
presidente de república dominicana luis
abinader
11.9 millones de archivos se
evidenciaron que 14 despachos crearon
sociedades en diferentes paraísos
fiscales usadas para llevar a cabo
diferentes transacciones se trata de la
mayor filtración de la historia
superando ampliamente los ya conocidos a
panamá papers que fueron publicados en
el 2016 que abrió un debate mundial
sobre estos casos de corrupción también
de evasión de impuestos y llevó a
mejorar la legislación al respecto
aparentemente ya lo vamos a ver en el
análisis para profundizar este tema
saludamos a luis moreno de los
coordinadores de justicia fiscales de la
red latindadd de él se conecta desde la
ciudad de lima en perú también está con
nosotros ricardo martner él es encargado
de la comisión independiente de la
fiscalidad corporativa internacional y
es ex jefe de la unidad de asuntos
fiscales de la cepal según esta
conversación desde ciudad de pucón en
chile y está con nosotros en el estudio
de france 24 nuestra compañera maría
camila fernando hernández miembro de la
alianza editorial el espectador conectas
para papeles a pandora ella participó en
la investigación para el capítulo de
colombia ustedes también nuestros
televidentes pueden participar a través
de las redes sociales en el debate bueno
si están funcionando porque algunas de
ellas han estado caídas pero pueden
participar a través de facebook
instagram y twitter france24 ese es la
cuenta también arroba santi luego es mi
cuenta personal les recuerdo que nuestra
etiqueta es numeral el debate efe 24
esperamos todos sus comentarios y sus
preguntas me advierten también del
departamento de redes que hay una
encuesta en este momento a través de las
redes sociales de france 24 para que
ustedes participen y dejen allí sus
impresiones comienzo en el estudio de
france 24 preguntándole a maría camila
por el origen de esta investigación ya
había dos antecedentes a nivel
internacional que dieron revuelo fue un
escándalo a nivel internacional cómo se
gestó este tercer episodio de esta
filtración de documentos que evidencia
estos dineros de personas importantes
influencias a nivel internacional en
paraísos fiscales bueno buenas noches
santiago muchas gracias por la
invitación primero que todo hay que
decir que además de ser la filtración
más grande que ha habido hasta el
momento de este de este tipo de
documentos
es diferente con respecto a las
anteriores porque tenemos información y
documentación de 14 firmas diferentes
panamá papers por ejemplo que es la
filtración que hasta el momento había
tenido más impacto era información que
provenía de un solo proveedor que pues
como todos sabemos es mozart con seca
que se hizo tristemente famoso después
de esto en este caso tenemos 14 firmas
diferentes que han operado en 38
jurisdicciones que han y que han
implementado esta industria offshore en
muchísimos países y que por lo tanto
tienen también clientes de todas partes
del mundo entonces eso a nivel
periodístico pues impone un reto
además de ser la filtración más grande
también es la colaboración periodística
más grande que se ha dado hasta el
momento
más de 600 periodistas en todo el mundo
117 medios
muchísimos países entonces a nivel
periodístico digamos fue fueron meses de
trabajo en los que además se tuvo que
analizar diferentes tipos de archivos no
muchos incluso en escritos a mano fue un
reto liderado por él por el consorcio de
periodistas de investigación que
comparten con sus medios aliados en todo
el mundo esta documentación y hacen todo
un análisis muy riguroso y pues nosotros
los medios de todo el mundo pues
entramos a revisar todos esos documentos
ya tratar de investigar cada uno de sus
países con contactos propios que tienen
los medios allí en cada uno de los
territorios paso a preguntarle al luis
moreno en la ciudad de lima ya lo
mencionamos tercera vez tercera
investigación
tercera filtración a nivel mundial que
vuelve otra vez a sacudir
es muy importante es muchos mandatarios
millonarios empresarios jefes de estado
reyes incluso veíamos al rey de jordania
esto deja en evidencia que los líderes
mundiales siguen enviando su dinero para
hacer transacciones a cuentas offshore o
empresas offshore en paraísos fiscales
no nos ha enseñado nada entonces las
otras dos experiencias
buenas noches santiago buenas noches al
panel también muchas gracias por la
invitación
efectivamente bueno no son estas dos
últimas filtraciones no si no son un
conjunto de filtraciones que lo largo de
estos años se han ido revelando e
incluso
como como señala maría camila esta es
una de las más grandes que incluso
algunas otras como los de swiss lic son
lux leaks y otras tanto en los pueblos
para despejarse cetera confirma volver a
confirmar justamente como este
esta estructura financiera opaca
offshore
sigue permitiendo justamente el traslado
artificial de inmensas
millones de dólares en ganancias por un
conjunto de como se ha señalado y ha
revele revela el pandora paper so los
papeles de pandora el traslado
artificial de las ganancias estas
jurisdicciones opacas que permiten
justamente primero ofrecer una bajo a
nivel o nula tributación a los
residentes ahí y también guardar
justamente el secretismo de quienes son
los que están justamente trasladando
estas estas riquezas pueden ser bien
habidas como la vida es a estas
jurisdicciones opacas
entonces
digamos hay todos digamos un proceso que
se ha venido realizando desde hace más
de diez o quince años con estas
diferentes filtraciones que de alguna
manera ha permitido algunos organismos
reguladores
intergubernamentales a empezar a
proponer normas de reestructuración del
sistema fiscal internacional pero tal
parece que aún todavía dada esas
diversas reformas que se vienen tratando
hoy vienen implementando diversos países
no son las suficientes ni son las
adecuadas parece todavía para poder
seguir impulsando digamos justamente el
cerrar estas brechas que de erosión de
la base tributaria que nos deja
justamente en un contexto de pandemia
una enorme pobreza no justo más en un
contexto de la pandemia que tanto
requieren los recursos nuestros en
plantearnos ricardo martner en la ciudad
de pucón en el sur de chile le hago la
misma pregunta vemos que entonces ha
habido pocos cambios poca evolución en
la parte legislativa y en el
comportamiento de las autoridades
principalmente por los países que fueron
señalados a lo largo de estas tres
investigaciones y de los paraísos
fiscales
hola muy buenas tardes muchas gracias
por la invitación puede que haya algún
rezago porque estoy efectivamente en un
lugar con poco con poca capacidad de
internet así que me disculpo por eso
puedo entiendo que por lo menos me
escuchan bien lo vimos y lo vemos
perfecto no se preocupe ricardo y muchas
gracias
lo primero es que es recordar que el
nombre de paraíso fiscal es algo
bastante
español digamos no porque en inglés en
el fondo lo que se quería decir eran
guaridas fiscales el fiscal jaime y
entonces que seguramente se describe
mejor lo que está ocurriendo en este
momento porque son lugares para ocultar
información generar opacidad en las
operaciones y en los patrimonios de las
personas y de pasar
o impuestos por aquí y por allá
uno de los presidentes que está
efectivamente
nombrado e investigado por esta inmensa
labor que han hecho a nivel global es
sebastián piñera el presidente de chile
el cuarto hombre más rico del país y que
que ha tenido la gentileza de darle una
donación a sus hijos en la isla se en
alguna de las islas paraísos fiscales
sabemos que una taza normal de donación
es del 25% entonces ahí pareciera haber
un evidente intento de evadir me va a ir
impuestos a los millonarios esperar esa
manera de estar evadiendo impuestos y lo
que quiero decir también es que se
mencionó en el reportaje interesante de
que esto implica 40
mil millones de dólares para para
américa latina y en realidad la
elevación de la importa la renta de
cuatro y medio puntos del pib es decir
en torno a doscientos mil millones de
dólares estamos hablando de un obvio
tributario que es absolutamente
gigantesco en la región flat y una
sorpresa y que haya digamos presidente
que tiene involucrado en esto porque
este límite entre empresariado y
política es muy tenue en nuestra red es
muy es muy fino sigo la ronda a la
inversa continuó con riccardo para que
responda rápidamente sobre la carga
moral o ética que tiene esto por ejemplo
en el caso de chile donde un empresario
exitoso millonario es además el
presidente del país aquí el balance
entre la ética la moral y el deber como
presidente es lo que está en juego
porque necesariamente tener dinero o
crear empresas en paraísos fiscales no
necesariamente es ilegal ya vamos a
hablar en detalle qué es lo ilegal a
través de esos paraísos fiscales pero
pero quiero que le demos en el caso de
chile de la carga qué puede haber ahí
ética sobre el presidente
ya hay una carga moral fenomenal desde
la explosión de octubre de 2019 un
presidente que está terminando sus
funciones con un 12 por ciento de
aprobación y que con esto seguramente
seguirá su tendencia de ser el ente
evidentemente un tema moral bueno piñera
ha sido presidente dos veces
y democráticamente elegido yo tengo la
sensación de que este tema de ser
empresario exitoso genera una esperanza
para los ciudadanos de mayor empleo tal
vez o mayores o mayor capacidad de
generar recursos en fin todo eso que
se ve en un hombre exitoso digamos que
luego se traslada a la esperanza de los
ciudadanos pero yo creo que claramente
esta vez la que ha aprendido la lecture
louis en la ciudad de lima en perú ahora
sí hablemos y expliquemos en detalle
estos paraísos fiscales pues
necesariamente tener allí empresas
creadas no necesariamente implica algo
ilegal que es lo ilegal que se puede
hacer a través de las de estas empresas
creadas allí o de cuentas que se pueden
tener en bancos internacionales allí le
hago la pregunta porque conversando con
colegas en la redacción de france24 esta
pregunta fue recurrente que porque era
ilegal y que no era ilegal dentro de
estos paraísos fiscales
y justamente ahí yo creo una línea
delgada entre lo que se denomina la
evasión fiscal y la ilusión fiscal no
entre lo que es justamente
permisivo y lo que es ilícito no y ahí
es donde entra justamente el término de
la moral que ya se está se ha estado
trabajando también en espacios de
regulación internacional no el 'tax
moral la moral la moral tributaria y ahí
entra justamente el juego de como
también en este sistema
pernicioso existe justamente los
denominados
facilitadores de los flujos financieros
ilícitos no o sea aquellos
entes o hombres o mecanismos que
facilitan justamente este traslado
artificial buscando en los vacíos
legales que tienen las legislaciones
alrededor de nuestros países para estar
en el filo justamente entre lo legal lo
no legal y lo que es de lo que
justamente ilícito lo que está ligado
mucho a la moral entonces ahí
básicamente digamos el gran poder
corporativo
y las grandes riquezas se amparan
justamente en estos facilitadores que
básicamente son los grandes bufetes de
abogados que terminan haciendo estas
planificaciones fiscales agresivas para
buscar justamente estos vacíos o esas
lagunas fiscales para poder de alguna
manera éste justamente transferir
artificialmente esta ganancia a estos
lugares de poca o nula tributación y de
mucho secretismo no que les permite
justamente obtener digamos esa
esa
para ocultamiento de esta riqueza para
no tributar justamente donde la han
generado
la residencia de estos de estos lugares
pero también y al mismo tiempo esto
estaba al lado digamos por un sistema
fiscal un sistema perdón financiero muy
opaco y oscuro no que incluso también se
empieza a crear mecanismos para ocultar
digamos este les trasladó
artificial de riqueza a través del
sistema financiero con la creación
posible empleo de estas estrategias o
estructuras como puede ser la banca en
la sombra shadow banking para ofrecer
justamente ese secretismo digamos
entonces hay ahí hay muchos eso y
justamente como se había señalado los
flujos financieros ilícitos en américa
latina representan aproximadamente 43
mil millones de dólares
que están justamente
facilitados y los principales
digamos reguladores o momentos que
vulneran digamos esos flujos ilícitos
está relacionada justamente eso lo que
les lleva a la inversión extranjera
directa el comercio y el deposición de
verbos en cuentas oscuras no para camila
con el estudio de france 24 a lo largo
de esta investigación ustedes nos decía
fueron varios meses analizando
diferentes tipos de documentos
y pudo usted evidenciar de los
documentos que usted encontró si es más
una desconfianza en el sistema de cada
uno de los países en el caso suyo en el
sistema colombiano en el sistema de pago
de los impuestos en el sistema
financiero del país o es simplemente que
predomina la corrupción predomina la
necesidad de sacar el dinero para poder
hacer todo tipo de negocios por fuera
pues santiago yo creo que hay un poco de
todo si uno ve casos como el de
venezuela claramente hay una
desconfianza en el sistema pero hay
casos en los que por ejemplo los grandes
capitales pues quieren sino evadir por
lo menos eludir ciertos impuestos y en
otros casos también personas
cuestionadas que buscan ocultar
capitales entonces lo que pasa con esta
es esta industria offshore es que
permite un rango de clientes muy amplio
precisamente por la falta de
transparencia que ofrece y la
confidencialidad que lo caracterizan yo
yo de esta de esta investigación a nivel
periodístico
destacaría hablando un poco de lo que le
pregunta ahorita de cómo se diferencia y
qué ha pasado desde panamá papers y las
otras filtra las filtraciones es el
número tan grande tan grande de
beneficiarios finales que se encuentran
en esta filtración es decir de personas
de las personas reales de las empresas
que es un número mucho mayor de lo que
se han encontrado en filtraciones
pasadas tanto cuando hablo de años
reales hablo de personas jurídicas y
personas naturales nada más digamos a
nivel de américa un número de políticos
muy muy grande de hecho es el continente
donde más se identificaron políticos 92
políticos en la filtración y
la fecha de los documentos porque pues
se pensaría que después de panamá papers
pues como se ha hablado y seguramente si
hubo avances pero lo que nos muestra
esta filtración es que la mayoría de los
documentos son de entre 1996 y 2020 y
panamá papers fue en 2016 entonces
significa que esta industria pues sigue
en movimiento siguió moviéndose sin
ningún tipo de cambios digamos
destacados o de gran calado para para
haber restringido un poco este tipo de
operaciones maría camila estas personas
naturales o jurídicas que usted menciona
que son los beneficiarios son personas
que necesariamente aparecen ya como
declarantes en sus países o son personas
que reciben estos dineros y también
pasan por debajo de la cuerda que vieron
ustedes en la investigación bueno pues
uno de los grandes retos a nivel
periodístico es que hay hay un cierto
punto al que nosotros no podemos llegar
y es saber hasta qué punto estas
personas están realmente evadiendo
impuestos en sus países no porque esta
es una información reservada en todos
los países por ejemplo pues en colombia
la mayoría de funcionarios y personas
públicas que es en donde nos enfocábamos
nosotros editorialmente pues dijeron que
ellos habían declarado todas sus
empresas según la reglamentación en la
legislación del país pero llega un punto
hasta de la
labor periodista periodística puede
llegar y de ahí en adelante pues deben
ser las autoridades de cada país que
puedan mirar eso nosotros lo que
queremos mostrar es cómo funciona esta
industria y por qué a la gente al
ciudadano como le tiene que importar
porque al final está vacío no está
elusión pues impacta en el bolsillo de
todos claro y en la inversión que haya
para el país y sobre todo en coyunturas
como la que estamos desde la pandemia
riccardo a los gobiernos a lo largo de
estos años que han sido dadas a conocer
estas filtraciones les ha interesado
seguir el caso como dice maría camila ya
pasa a las manos de las autoridades
empezar a hacer investigaciones esto ha
avanzado en el caso de chile han tomado
cartas en el asunto o simplemente lo han
dejado pasar
es una muy buena pregunta ya del caso
del caso pero yo diría que hay dos
cuestiones que son bastante
fundamentales una es que qué autonomía
tienen las administraciones tributarias
para investigar a su propio presidente
por ejemplo o sea claramente ahí hay una
dificultad
muy muy grande y sobre todo denunciar en
fin así es que ahí tenemos un problema
de instituciones de fortalecimiento a
las instituciones tributarias que abarca
toda la región ciertamente muchas de las
personas públicas han estado con estos
problemas y no han tenido mayores
problemas judiciales y lo segundo es
desincentivar los paraísos fiscales como
se hace es nosotros n click donde
trabajo es que soy comisionado en la
fiscalidad por la reforma de la
fiscalidad internacional
todos
estos días en los que se está
discutiendo el poner un impuesto mínimo
no es cierto un impuesto mínimo tiene
alguna manera de se incentive el uso de
los paraísos fiscales en la medida en
que ya no va a estar en el sentido
tributario para para trasladar esa
inmensa cantidad de dinero al exterior
entonces es un tema muy fundamental que
se está discutiendo en estos días a
nivel internacional
y además el hecho de que también es muy
importante que está empezando a
funcionar que el intercambio automático
de información que se llama que
efectivamente las gráficas tributarias
ya van a saber lo que tiene la persona o
la empresa o la corporación en el
exterior por lo menos lo declarado por
cada uno de los países involucrados en
este proceso entonces eso va a generar
muchos muchos avances ahora lo que a mí
me preocupa de la capacidad de
fiscalización de las administraciones
tributarias porque sabemos que son
extremadamente débiles tenemos grandes
periodistas que nos informan de esto
pero luego queda un tanto diluido en el
serio sistema la institucionalidad es un
punto a analizar louis hay un punto que
me llama la atención estudiando sobre
este tema y es el papel que tiene eeuu
usted mencionaba que no hay destacados
políticos o multimillonarios de eeuu en
esta filtración pero eeuu es tal vez el
que se inventó esta fórmula y citan
algunos de sus estados como por ejemplo
dakota del sur pero también ve a uno el
reino unido
qué es un país cuyos territorios de
ultramar muchos de ellos son paraísos
fiscales kallman
bermuda la isla de mann las islas del
canal de ayer seaworld si son todos
paraísos fiscales nadie les regula esto
al reino unido qué pasa con estos dos
países a qué juegan ellos en el
escenario internacional en este sector
si algo algo interesante es que estas
filtraciones en realidad no apuntan
mucho a los políticos por ejemplo
norteamericanos o algún gran digamos
grandes riquezas en eeuu que si si si de
alguna manera apuntan digamos las
filtraciones a recoger información de
que sale de algunos de los centros que
normalmente se conocen como de
proveedores de secretismo entre panamá
pero también se incluye digamos algunas
jurisdicciones como las islas vírgenes
británicas
dakota del sur
pero si es efectivamente una de las de
las críticas que ha salido que sigue
saliendo es porque por ejemplo suiza no
se recoge mucha información desde que
como centro de provisión de servicios
financieros offshore o en los mismos
países bajos son mismos chipre como bien
señaló las islas vírgenes británicas no
que son territorios que proveen
justamente este tipo de
servicios
visibilidad digamos es importante
digamos a y el rol también que está
jugando los grandes países las grandes
economías con las grandes potencias para
regular de alguna manera no sé si
decirlo entre comillas digamos este este
sistema o esta estructura opción pero
como bien se señala aquí se requiere la
necesidad como también mencionaba
ricardo anteriormente de fortalecer y
dotar de capacidades a las mismas
administraciones tributarias y los
organismos de control pero eso también
suele resultar un poco
problemático cuando
incluso y hemos visto existe estas pues
puertas giratorias es decir que lo vemos
digamos en diversas instancias de los
gobiernos no de donde gerentes o dueños
de empresas terminan siendo
presidentes ocurran un cargo de
dirección o ministerial no y que
terminan legislando no a favor de una
regulación que nos lleve hacia a la
progresividad fiscal no es decir hacer
que los que más tienen tributen más sino
que por el contrario terminan haciendo
unas reformas regresivas donde hacen que
no sean los grandes digamos millonarios
o las grandes riquezas que tributen sino
que sean las personas de a pie quienes
sostengan el futuro de su propio
desarrollo
entonces eso también juega un rol un rol
importante y organismos de regulación
internacional también juegan un rol un
rol destacado digamos en la regulación
de las normas de como el sistema
financiero tributario internacional se
está llevando a cabo no louis le pido
por favor que me responda más puntual
porque ya estoy llegando al final del
programa y me quedan varios temas por
analizar maría camila a nivel
periodístico esto trae consecuencias
para los medios de comunicación en un
país como colombia donde hay críticas de
censura donde hay amenazas no es el
único país donde sucede pero esto trae
repercusiones para los periodistas y
para los medios
pues yo creo que depende de él
del momento y de la de las garantías que
se ofrezcan los periodistas de cada país
obviamente ahí hay una presión natural
después de revelar este este tipo de
cosas
pero pues creo que es lo natural cuando
uno expone
lo que algunos poderosos o figuras
políticas y públicas quieren mantener
oculto porque al final de eso se trata
esta industria del secretismo y de
mantener algo oculto de
la opinión pública pero tocan fibras de
poder importantes que puede traer
repercusiones lo digo por el caso de
colombia que sabemos lo que puede pasar
en este país vamos llegando a la recta
final del programa quiero llegar a las
conclusiones entonces comienzo por
riccardo en la ciudad de pucón en el sur
de chile que va a pasar con este nuevo
escándalo vamos a ver regulaciones vamos
a ver
legislaciones al respecto una mayor
capacidad de las instituciones para
ejercer un poco más de control o
simplemente será otro capítulo qué pasa
bueno un poco de las dos cosas
seguramente pero lo interesante es que
mantiene viva la agenda progresiva en
materia de impuestos en américa latina
porque muchas personas hablan de un
modelo económico en que va a pagar pocos
impuestos para por ejemplo o
incentivar la inversión pero la verdad
es que las cosas no funcionan así
primero tributamos y luego conversamos y
de esa manera reduciendo las extensiones
tributarias por ejemplo vamos a lograr
una mayor capacidad del estado para
atender los tres menos necesidad de
nuestro país riccardo para entonces como
cómo combatir la evasión y que la gente
pague impuestos y que estas grandes
fortunas paguen impuestos en sus países
es una gran pregunta pero que decía que
primero hay que ganar la batalla de las
ideas y en eso estamos porque como digo
es necesario tener una agenda desde
mayor tribuna tributación progresista
progresiva puesto que somos los países
con la menor recaudación
en materia de impuestos directos del
mundo
no creemos psd los se deben claro
como primero fortalecer los talentos de
la fiscalización en materia de
administración y luego una firme
convicción política para efectivamente
generar reforma legislativa importante
importante de punto riccardo paso a luís
en la ciudad de lima qué consecuencias
va a traer esto veremos a las
autoridades actuando veremos arrestos
veremos investigaciones que vamos a ver
de aquí en adelante los próximos meses
porque esto apenas está comenzando
si de todas maneras yo creo que de
alguna manera van a haber ayuda un poco
a la judicialización de algunos de los
procesos que ya se han venido trabajando
y que están en marcha no por ejemplo en
el caso del perú que que termina por
sacar a la luz justamente la utilización
de la sociedad offshore en el caso de
pedro pablo kuczynski no que ya es parte
del proceso de esta investigación
alrededor de la baja de la recepción de
dinero al parecer y ilícito soy para
ocultar información entonces de repente
se va a ahondar un poquito más en
algunos procesos pero va a depender como
dice creo ricardo de la decisión
política que suman los gobiernos frente
digamos esta filtración y la información
que va saliendo solamente para detallar
que es de nosotros desde desde sociedad
civil seguimos impulsando digamos todo
el trabajo por ejemplo para fortalecer
el sistema fiscal internacional con la
creación de los registros de
beneficiarios finales a nivel nacional
el intercambio automático de información
avanzar por ejemplo en una creación de
un registro global de activos entre las
diversas administraciones tributarias y
gobiernos para que colaboren entre sí
sin saber a dónde está justamente
identificada esta riqueza e incluso
también ir más allá en una articulación
en el seno de la administraciones unidas
donde queremos que sería digamos el
espacio adecuado para poder aportar a
este debate y camila minutos para el
cierre esto sin duda alguna es
fundamental que el periodismo siga
develando todo este tipo de
investigaciones
mientras más investigaciones similares
más filtraciones no se están
sobrepasando ustedes y de pronto yendo
un poco más allá y señalando como dicen
algunos políticos que es una persecución
bueno pues yo creo que no soy el primero
no sé no sabemos y que vendrán más
investigaciones de estas ahora estamos
empezando a revelar todo lo que hay en
en esta caja de pandora
acerca de lo que dicen los políticos de
la persecución pues yo creo que el hecho
de que sean figuras públicas y
funcionarios les los obliga a rendir
cuentas ante la ciudadanía que como dije
antes pues se ve afectada por este tipo
de prácticas abusivas y pues desde el
periodismo seguiremos manteniendo viva
la agenda como dijo ricardo de este tema
de la tributación y de las prácticas
fiscales abusivas mientras podamos
hacerlo para camila muchas gracias por
haber estado con nosotros a luisa
ricardo también muchas gracias por haber
estado con nosotros aquí en el debate a
ustedes muchas gracias por la sintonía y
le recuerdo que ahora el debate está del
lunes a jueves a las 7 y 20 hora de
bogotá aquí en france 24
sigan con nuestra programación
[Música]